[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thanks for listening
thanks for being here ryan thanks for
having me yeah i have to have you you
know i couldn't do it without you you
could do this all on your own no way
it'd be boring as [ __ ] you you had fun
it's nice to have you here i'm fun yeah
i think you're fun
thanks yeah i don't like to be alone i
think you know that about me i think
that's the main thing yeah i don't like
to be alone no
do you
i i could be alone yeah all right well
fine i could i could do this
you know i think what we're saying is i
should do this
switch around yeah i'll just do this
and then um
just hang out
i think that works guys thank you so
much for listening to the podcast today
if you enjoy it today if you're here for
uh alan richton and you enjoy it i hope
you'll write a review you'll follow us
on our handles which are at
insideyoupodcast on twitter and
instagram at insideyoupod on
facebook uh right not inside of your
podcast on facebook oh instagram and
facebook is at insidetou
podcast and insideipod on the twitter
and write a review and listen you can
watch it on youtube
uh i hope you're with us i hope you
listen to us uh weekly and not just for
you know intermittently you want people
to listen to you and hopefully like the
interviews that you're bringing yes you
know what i mean i know what you mean
i'm a little slow this morning a little
slow
it is two o'clock in the afternoon is it
two o'clock in the afternoon it is when
we're recording for you we got a great
guest today uh
jack reacher is coming out jack reacher
is out
uh it'll be out when this airs so check
out jack reacher allen has worked
incredibly hard uh my guest today is
some
crazy stories i couldn't believe how
open and honest
uh
allen was it's great it's a good one i
mean he talks sometimes where i just
looked at him like holy [ __ ] dude this
is
yeah i mean he really got deep and
you're gonna
learn a lot and i think you're gonna
respect him for his uh
his sincerity his vulnerability his uh
just being down to earth and real
uh guys i want to thank all my patrons
if you're listening and you don't know
what a patreon is you go to patreon.com
inside of you p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash inside of you um
people who give back to the podcast
without patrons i don't know where this
podcast would be but you guys really
keep it going
and um those that give back you can look
on there there's tiers there's a top
tier where i send packages to you every
four months
um
i do youtube lives it's a it's a family
affair it's a lot of fun i really love
it um i just did a uh
what you might call it a zoom with all
my top tier patrons cool and we had a
zoom we had a nice chat it was really
lovely uh also the inside you online
store
is open is around we have some
smallville scripts signed by me small
the lunch box we have uh pictures we
have inside you mugs we have new mugs we
have tons of stuff go to the inside of
you online store and check that out also
i'm on cameo you could get a nice fun
happy cameo for me this isn't that great
nice like for instance ryan if you were
uh if you got a cameo from me
ryan dude hey
happy freaking birthday buddy it's your
friend here why don't i just get one
right now well i'm giving you one right
here you can just edit this out
i'm getting a free cameo yeah you got
the free cameo
um
i want to thank everybody for coming to
see uh my band sunspin we did a live
virtual show we do one at the end the
last saturday of every month i really
appreciate it uh we'll be informing you
on upcoming shows but again listen to
the show write a review i i really hope
you do and without further ado why don't
we just get inside of alan richmond it's
my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience i mean you're doing a lot of
press right now
jack reacher is a huge show it's gonna
be a huge show on amazon well we hope
you hope people watch it yeah i hope
yeah i hope that 200 million people that
have read the books
you know want to watch the show i think
they'll probably give it a shot i think
the movie was a big success you gotta be
intrigued
yeah i think so yeah i mean and it's
good it's faithful man it's very
faithfully adapted to for those that
don't know
i play reacher on the tv series it was a
film it's also
there's 26 seven books
are there 27 books really a lot of books
holy [ __ ] how do they write that much
about jack reacher what's so interesting
about jack reacher have you read the
books i'm not a big reader frozen bob
have you read the books ryan i'm not a
jack reader no guys not jack reader this
is like the second highest selling book
of all time do you read harry potter
have you ever read the hairbrush i did
read some harry potter of course you did
you know i'm
i read two of them i wrote i read uh the
first one
and the second one
unbelievable yeah i'm more into
non-fiction but uh right but for
watching a television program like
self-help books well sure i'm trying to
work on myself nowadays i do the same
thing do you
you know on your instagrams
you're very uh open very personable and
uh welcoming and i really appreciate
that you're very humble like i i see
your instagram lives that you do that
what is what inspired you to do that
what are you doing
yeah that's a good question um thanks
for that by the way yeah um
you know i had an i i guess like an
early midlife crisis
really and uh yeah how old are you i've
been very open about it um i'm 39 now
you're 39. yeah how old are you i'm 49.
how old are you 33. oh a baby photo
infant take your diaper off and change
it yeah change his diaper right now yeah
but wow so you had a midlife crisis i
think i'm having one of those now my
past four years yeah and in what way
just overwhelmed uh anxious uh
had a little bout of depression had a
little uh you know there's a lot of
things that just kind of escalated so
what so depression though this is
something i dealt with for the first
time and and you know i have an
understanding of what i think i
personally this is not like i'm not a
scientist here you know i think i
understand where depression comes from
talk about it but what is it for you i
just curious where where are you um i
think it's these these uh i think you
know they always say the past is
depression and the future is anxiety
when you're thinking into the future
you're thinking anxiety anything in the
past is through depression um i think
with me
is uh when i get anxious or when i i'm
in pain i i almost feel a sense of i'm
not
whole i'm not complete i'm not perfect
i'm not all these things and it gives me
anxiety thinking how do i get back to
normalcy and what is normalcy and uh
well when i was 30s i could and i think
when i in my 20s and 30s i could deal
with high levels of stress and get
through it because i was young and
everything was you know i was more i
don't know if i was more athletic but i
was just younger and then at a certain
level the same stresses were there but
my body wasn't taking it in like it did
it wasn't uh
it was kind of wrecking me right so you
know
i'm like why am i always [ __ ] tired
my friend tom's like because you're
[ __ ] 49 dude i'm like no that's not
it i'm always tired though i'm always
people like are you okay you're a little
tired i'm like [ __ ] you i hate when
people do i hate when people say you
look tired especially for somebody like
myself who's you know i regenerate alone
like that's when i'm you know i can go
you know people see like the characters
that i do they're so high energy but
when i'm when i'm by myself i'm not like
i'm like doing mountains of blow off the
coffee table you know i'm just i'm
retreating into myself into my thoughts
and right and so people see that in and
they think that kind of isolation is
like there's something wrong with you
right drives me crazy as a performer
people expect you to sort of be on and
if you're not there's something wrong
with it that's exactly right that and i
feel like that's you and i are uh
we share that that people always think
of me as uh hyper or you know always on
and being funny and the second that i'm
not something's wrong with right right
and uh you know that's yeah i've had to
deal with that my whole life but also
when i think when you talk about
depression
depression can you know really be the
past could be things that have like sort
of happened in your childhood things
that have happened
that you haven't addressed trauma and
trauma certain trauma so there's
everybody has their demons and
you know i'm you know i work through
mine with therapy and you know try to
exercise and
but uh i'm just
i expect more out of myself and that's a
lot a lot to handle like i always
like you can't be tired you're not
allowed to be tired you can't you
and and i'm like well what's wrong with
me that i can't
you know uh
and i'm just yeah i have to i do have to
put things into perspective like you
aren't 38 39 you are 49 you're gonna get
more tired right you're gonna deal
you know but not only that but we live
in a culture right now that right now we
have the western culture you know as
long as capitalism has been around
that feeds this idea into our minds from
the a very young age that says if you
aren't grinding yourself down you're not
you're not working hard enough and if
you don't work hard enough you won't be
successful you know this correlation
between hard work and fatigue and
success
elon musk you know i think tweeted
recently something that was just sort of
you know if you're not working 80 90
hours a week you're not you know you
don't deserve it whatever it is you're
after i don't know you know that's a lot
not quoting him but but you know
and it's um you know the fact that we
should feel like you know we deserve
poverty or somebody deserves poverty
because they decide to rest their body a
little bit is a ridiculous idea
you know i mean yeah that idea that like
we you know we should be we should be
going all the time it's
crazy it's crazy it's good that's right
i think it's what kills us that's crazy
i think what's what tortures us is that
we just don't take a break from it we
don't uh give ourselves a moment right
yeah and i think that's kind of what it
was for me you know i mean i think it's
a couple things you talk about trauma
certainly regret and shame has something
to do with
the present state of feeling depressed
you know um but i think um i think
really for me i think at its core
the the deepest
tap root of depression has to do with
purpose and and uh when we stray from
purpose or we don't understand our
purpose
meaning why we're here and what we're
supposed to be doing with everything
that you know is within our orbit um i
think you know that's just a one red
flag you know depression um you know but
you know also like a very the you know
from a very realistic standpoint a
scientific standpoint brain incoherency
is a very real thing that nobody really
talks what is that
you know we've got these five brain
waves right that the alpha the beta you
know they're all fighting for supremacy
at any one time you know and we are very
good at remaining in the the one brain
wave from the time that we wake up in
the morning the time that we go to sleep
that is the most high energy most
demanding most sapping it's one that we
feel like we can problem solve present
in the moment it's almost fight or
flight
but that's not how we were made to exist
that's something that we should be able
to tap into and then and then you know
turn that gear off you know switch the
transmission a little bit and we're
better in um a brainwave state that's
more calm and reflective and meditative
and we find that our high creative you
know the most creative uh versions of
ourself um is usually expressed in that
brainwave state which we have to force
ourselves
into you know especially with all the
noise that we have in culture and how do
we do that through meditation
prayer things that they just don't
really
embed in your heart
slowing down and meditating is not part
of the conversation that's not part of
the you know successful equation if you
know if there's a formula for success
today like we would you know it was just
saying it's not
it's not slowing down and thinking or
finding ways to just move you know um
um you know like you know there's uh
there's these adult swing sets that that
are that are being built that are just
about creating a motion for your brain
that actually can help trigger a
response with your brain waves that are
you know really yeah like surfing is
also but you know there's certain ways
to create a flow for your brain that
actually put it in a certain state you
know um
but that when when we're in this
frenetic brain energy that's taxing um
all the time
and you know the body really wants to be
somewhere else that incoherency is
detrimental to our spirit our body all
that you know so um
so i think when we're when we are
incoherent and everything sort of all
are battling at the same time for some
some healthy state in us um
we might feel or express that as like
this feeling of depression i think of
like i can't handle this you know how
old were you when you got this when you
had this call so-called midlife crisis
what you call it yeah probably uh i
think i was uh maybe 36 35 35 so you've
already at this point you have three
boys right so you have three kids you're
married and then i might want to say you
decide to have a midlife crisis you have
a midlife yeah i mean but you know i
think for me it was a matter of you know
you know you think i think when you have
kids
there's a part of you that thinks
there's no way
it can ever go wrong for me i have to
find a way to make everything go right
because look at what i am responsible
for now scary you know like there's no
you know i'm not there's no luxury of
making mistakes anymore you know or bad
decisions or whatever
and unfortunately you find that like
you know like all things you know
marriage you know people sometimes don't
don't use marriage to fix your
relationship you know those problems
will follow you same thing with kids
like i think some people think i didn't
go into having kids thinking this but
you know
there's a pressure you know as any
decent human being i think would have to
go like i have to
provide i don't want to stability yeah i
don't want to fail and i don't want to
like fall apart and i don't want to
it's
you know another way to say it is like i
no longer have the luxury of discovering
who i am
i have to just know
that moment this instant now i'm a
father
i better know who i am because if i
don't there's something
terribly wrong with this situation
that's going to be that's terrifying you
know yeah i don't have to deal with that
and i'm getting anxiety thinking about
it yeah well and and these are thoughts
i think that maybe we have with
ourselves like on a subconscious level
at least i did it wasn't something i
could vocalize at the time i didn't i i
think i knew somewhere deep down that
there was a bit of panic
but you're also you know you do what you
do especially when you're young where
you're like
you just i'm like you know
there's no problem here i can do this i
can do this and i'm gonna have to have
to do this i have to you have no choice
get up allen yeah
you got three kids get to [ __ ] work
let's go right that's what society and
whatever everybody's telling you sort of
like
and you are kind of falling apart at the
same time right trying to be this man
that you
can't possibly be or are trying to be
right
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy is uh somebody a company
that's been with me for a while now and
um
if you listen to the podcast you
understand why they're really helping
people they're helping people like my
friend ryan here ryan you still go to
better help i still go to better help
and how much is it helping you it is
helping immensely yeah a lot of my
friends are like is this was this the
real deal is better help i'm like yeah
man that's a lot of people are using it
and really liking it i get letters
all the time sent to me
that say hey thanks for you know your
better help um
sponsor because they're really helping
me and you know you definitely save a
lot more than going to you know just
getting in your car and going somewhere
um
you know those
therapy sessions are expensive as hell
yeah and better help is definitely a lot
cheaper uh you know many people think
that therapy is for uh
other people but utilizing therapy
doesn't mean something's wrong with you
it means you recognize that all humans
have emotions and we need to learn to
understand them not avoid them
and we've been taught
that taking care of our mental health
shouldn't be a part of everyday life but
that's a huge misconception
we take care of our bodies by exercising
going to the doctor eating well
focusing on and investing in the health
of our minds
is just as important
um
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to ryan do you see them
on camera i do you like that i like it i
think it helps for me it helps for you
like to see the person it's more of a
some contact some uh interaction it just
feels
yeah you just see some kind empathetic
faces across from you yeah i like that
no
like i said it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours look give it a try so many people
have tried this two million people have
been using better help online therapy
and inside of you listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's right ten percent
off for inside of your listeners off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
slash
inside inside of you is brought to you
by geico
ryan
do you rent or own your home i rent my
apartment i own my home and it's it's a
lot of work isn't it whether you have an
apartment or a house oh my goodness yeah
it is what are you always running around
you're always doing something there's
always something that needs to be fixed
yep but you know what's easy
say it bundling policies with geico
we all know the name geico geico makes
it easy for us to bundle your homeowners
or renters insurance along with your
auto policy because you know you already
have so much going on you don't have
time to do
these other things go to geico folks
it's so easy really it's easy i could do
this
go to geico.com get a quote see how much
you could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's geico.com inside
of you is brought to you by creatures of
habit creatures of habit is an
in-your-face lifestyle and wellness
brand rooted in delivering nutritional
healthy habits alongside cozy apparel
meet the prot agonist an incredibly
delicious highly optimized superhuman
oatmeal packed with 30 grams of
plant-based protein vitamin d3 omega-3
fatty acids probiotic and digestive
enzymes no this is not just oatmeal the
protagonist is your daily wellness
insurance designed and created for
convenience whether you're running out
the door or like to prep the night
before the protagonist comes in four
easy to whip up recipes just add hot
water overnight in the fridge in the
microwave or into a smoothie and because
we want you operating at your absolute
best in addition to being plant-based
the protagonist is also gluten-free soy
and dairy-free non-gmo and allergen free
raise your hand if you want to eliminate
stress and chaos from your morning
routines
we see you and we got you the pro
agonist does the trick every time
anywhere and for anyone take it on the
road when you're traveling on a camping
trip in your bag to work or the gym and
start every day with all the energy
living requires
hop over to creaturesofhabit.com
that's creatures with a k creatures of
habit.com and use promo code inside15
that's inside15 to get 15 off your first
purchase
creaturesofhabit.com with a k and use
promo code inside 15 for 15 off your
first order remember we are a direct
outcome of our daily habits some habits
will break you some will make you
creatures of habit is here to support
you on the journey of making greatness a
bigger part of your life
so do you feel like there's the pressure
of you you're trying to be the best dad
trying to be the best uh husband trying
to do all these things and that's what
part of it was yes and then trying to
reconcile that with reality which you
know um
there were
moments that i were very difficult you
know and
you know keeping my marriage together
was very difficult you know i was
you know as my career was accelerating
and i was working on bigger films with
bigger stars and um you know and then
realizing you know
not everybody that you work with cares
that you're married and you know there's
a lot of friction because some people
would rather you not be married and then
you're like maybe i shouldn't be married
right
you know it's very you know um uh it's a
difficult uh it's a difficult place to
be and
um
you know so there was a lot of growing
pains you know for somebody who grew up
very blue collar
um in north dakota and yeah i was born
in north dakota i was raised in illinois
in florida you know my i have a place in
florida now i live there now
um
you know uh being confronted with
you know
um
you know starlets and
you know films and the press and and
what people often you know attribute to
uh
the celebrity like the you know the red
carpets in the picture you know and i
mean you know there's like the glitz and
glam of it all which is not all it is at
all i'm not it's a very small part of it
right um and a part of it that doesn't
matter but um
you know being confronted with that and
going like oh there's this whole other
side of life that i had no idea existed
and now i'm being exposed to it but i'm
also married and i forgot the young kids
and
who i
who am i did i jump the gun here you
know i mean you have to die you start to
second guess yourself yeah i'd be lying
if i didn't say that you know i've been
very open with my wife about this you
know and you were enticed there was mo
yeah sure there's moments where like i
don't know if you know um i don't know
if the life i chose is the life i want
right now you know and then you so you
know and then you feel a huge amount of
guilt and shame for even thinking those
thoughts you know which
um so there was you know that was there
was sort of that thing like under the
cauldron a little bit um but then i you
know a bit bizarrely
for me it was i had a very good year
like a very good year wow but it was too
it was too much you know i took on every
you know i wrote i you know i write down
my goals at the beginning of the year
put it on paper let me put it out into
the world
i want to direct the film i want to sell
this script i want to sell a manuscript
for a book i want to do and everything
that i i every i ticked every box you're
making it happen yeah dude it was a good
year and um
you know reap the rewards from that
financially you know and uh
but servicing all those monsters that i
was creating was becoming too much and
so i had to force myself into this
brainwave state for nine months i like
made myself manic to
deal with this you know so i've got
identity issues
[Music]
issues do you understand that sure i
mean you know
you know not like i was talking about it
every day but just knowing that there's
something behind the the veil there
that's like i'm not sure who i am or
what my purpose is here in my marriage
or in my life or career
and then
i manic for for for far longer than i
should be to to service all these
masters
and uh and then i had the straw that i
think broke the camel's back was
um i had a business partner who i had
done everything right for you know i had
uh i you know honored faithfully all our
contracts like was doing uh great job
making uh successful business for honest
very honest and uh multiple audits by
some of the biggest auditing firms to
prove that because there were like false
allegations
when there was retribution for me
deciding to walk away but um i was
confronted with a business partner who
um gave me an ultimatum you know well
into our business dealings together like
if i didn't
provide this quid pro quo relationship
thing that she was gonna um destroy my
reputation and our businesses she didn't
care she had so much money anyway
and uh
you know
you know needing being confronted with
this sense of like well
you know i know i'm not perfect and i
have issues
but when you do it all right and this is
where you end up anyway in a in like a
long drawn-out legal battle
just trying to um
you know
you know protect your reputation because
you got somebody making these false you
know i mean i had lawyers calling me up
going you're dead meat buddy and i'm
like who is this and they're like we
know that you've been buying houses with
you know bitcoin and you've been taking
stealing money from the company and
you've been buying cars jesus i'm like
what are you talking about like i've
never audited me then there's nothing
worse than being innocent or not having
done anything wrong people are accusing
using you of it that's this is terrible
this person looked me and i said if you
don't come up to my hotel room right now
give me what i want
i'm gonna call tmz and tell them that
you are you you sexually assaulted me
tried to rape me and by the time you
holy by the time by the time you clear
it up
everybody will already think that you're
that you know like it won't matter the
damage will be done
like that to my face that threat and i
was like
you you're making a huge mistake like
this is that's not i mean and you're
feeling this yeah you're feeling the
stress you're feeling the anxiety yeah
dude all that man so um so so so you
know i flew home after that conversation
and a guy lawyered up you know to
protect myself and thankfully like
nothing ever happened you know that came
of it but um
but uh
you know that
coming coming out of that season of
busyness and and all that the manic
energy for far longer than we should
ever have to sustain that kind of energy
this
i you know this this
crisis of like
faith and humanity
you know um
a little bit of uncertainty of like
where i should be right now and identity
crisis a little bit yeah yeah
dude and you you came to your wife and
you told her honestly this is what i'm
feeling and this is what i'm thinking
and i don't want to ruin this marriage
but these are kind of what i came to her
and i said i think it's better if i'm
not here
really yeah and what'd she say
please don't do anything crazy
you know it was a very real conversation
like here meaning like if you weren't
alive yeah you were that bad you were
dark it was very i could not pull myself
out of it you know because once i once i
got settled down back in l.a
after all of it after all the dust
settled
i was like
i could i couldn't get up in the morning
like you know the things that you talk
about with depression like i could
only wanted to sleep all the time it
felt so foreign to me somebody with like
this zest for life and this energy
that's you know i mean this drive this
work ethic like it's it's insatiable and
to feel like i don't i can't get out of
bed
i didn't understand why i would want to
anyway and then feeling like now i'm
just a burden to my family that my kids
are seeing me like this i can't let them
see me like this this is i'm like this
shell of myself and they see me in bed
all day
it would just be better if i wasn't here
and uh wow uh yeah man and because i
know what that's like i know it's like
just waking up and going i just want to
go back to sleep i just want to lie down
yeah i don't have enough energy for the
day and that's depression huh
yeah
yeah but that but that depression is a
red flag for something much deeper which
for me was about purpose and i didn't
know i so i've been open about this i've
talked about this publicly on my little
channel my you know trying to help
people who maybe have felt like this and
don't understand it hold on just a
little longer because if you do hold on
just a little longer and you felt like
this there is hope for you there's hope
for a better day where we can remember
why we're here remember who we are and
and and take time to find our purpose
and sometimes that means a big shift
sometimes a little shift
for me
it still sort of fit my understanding of
the world but i needed to make it a
choice about who i wanted to be and
what that you know the consequences of
that would be in my outward life you
know and um
i didn't know that at the time i
couldn't speak to that at the time but i
uh i went up in my attic i had a
a
a big house with um
you know second story that i turned into
movie sets right and i went up in uh
this movie set that i'd shot in it it
was such a weird
such it's still such a weird thing to
think about but um
and i don't know why i went up there i
just felt like the only place to do this
the best place to do this i don't know
and i i uh i strung a green extension
cord around some rafters in my
set you know that's like there's no roof
it's a fly walls and stuff and um
and i hung myself
and you hung yourself yeah
yeah and it's still hard to think about
the fact that like i would do something
like that to myself especially with kids
but i
i i now understand what it's like
when people
are like i don't understand why they
would kill themselves and i'm like i can
tell you from experience
they thought they were giving the world
a gift
that is the saddest lie that we could
tell ourselves but geez i thought that i
was doing my family and my community a
favor because i i was such a mess
mentally like i in nobody ever tells you
that like when you get to the top
there's nothing there there's nothing
there there's just more of that if you
want it
you know i had ground and scraped and
fought to make movies and to make the
things that i wanted to make and to sell
books and sell scripts and i was doing
all those things and then i get there
and i'm like a broken shell of myself
with this relationship that threatened
to sort of like truly like wreck my life
and i had done nothing to deserve that
and you know i'm like what
what is life like what you know i'm so
backwards
uh right you thought everything that was
gonna make you happy didn't yes
everything you wanted to do you were
doing but you still weren't happy but i
was you know but i'm i'm a victim i'm
i'm uh i'm a product i should say of
these systems that we all
survive in which is you know this sort
of capitalist driven corporate uh
corporatocracy kind of driven um way of
of of
merchandising and commercializing every
um thought and fear and moment that we
have in our lives and um and never
giving us a chance to slow down and uh
you know when when i was able to i i
i was
on my way out and i saw my kids and i
saw them grown up
and
you really saw that yes i did
and um and i saw them asking me just
like like a mature
grown adult would say you know say
something very calmly without emotion
like please don't do this
it was such a
such a startling image that you know um
you know them saying we need you um that
i i climbed up out of that i pulled
myself up and i i got out of that and uh
was it hard to get out of that i mean
thank god i work out because i mean if i
didn't you wouldn't have been having i
would try this together you know but i
did and um
and uh you know so i got up there
and did you just get hysterical after
that yeah
just like kind of lost your mind for a
second yeah like this is where i am
what is wrong and this is after a good
year this is after making tons of money
this is after like this is after
accomplishing all the goals how c how
can that be like that's not something we
talk about
that that
that there's nothing there at the top
that like you know that life isn't
about you know jim carrey's said it
before you know i hope everybody gets
what they want and gets
the riches that their hearts desire so
they realize that there's no that's not
what life is all about that's not what
will make you happy um you know some
people have discovered that truth and
uh so you talk about what inspired me
to start talking about something more
meaningful on my channel
and it was this realization when i came
out of that i called a doctor that i'd
never talked to i had a therapy to
shrink in l.a
who
seemed to be able to help people like
this you know it was advertising that
kind of thing and i said i need
help
immediately like this hour
because i don't know what's going to
happen right i'm out of my mind
and um
and i he you know he sees me and
you know he it was the first time i ever
heard the word bipolar in my name in the
same sentence he goes we took some tests
together and he goes okay you're bipolar
bipolar one
a little bipolar you know and i was like
i go sorry for causing a lot of you know
i swear i know a lot of young people but
you know uh you follow me because of the
stuff that i talk about on my channel
but
i was so pissed i was like [ __ ] you man
and i'm still a little i'm a [ __ ] you
man i'm not i'm not [ __ ] you and he was
like okay like he's probably done this a
thousand times with people right but i
almost thought you'd feel like a relief
like no you know what it is you want to
put me in a box you want to put me in a
little category especially a category of
like basket cases like [ __ ] you man i'm
hell is your initial thought right yes
dude
no i resisted i resisted and then he
goes i think there's medication and like
[ __ ] you man i'm out and i left
i left and i like go down to the parking
garage and i'm like sweating and pissed
and
i know he's right you know i know he's
right
and i go back and i'm like um
i'm a little i'm having a hard time
dealing with this but let's talk about
what you know of this and then he goes
um we don't know a lot about bipolar and
i was so he goes but let's get you on
this medication a little metrogen and
i'm like what's lemotrogen and he's like
well it was used for anti-seizure you
know for epileptic
epileptic um people with epilepsy right
and um
and and they find that it kind of you
know it works for some reason um with uh
bipolar and i'm like how does it work
like what does it do and what does it
make me feel like it's like well i don't
know i don't know i was like you don't
know you're prescribed
everybody's different you know and it
started i started a journey of like
really studying this stuff and i i've
read every book on bipolar
i wanted better answers and now i
understand
a little bit more about it and i
definitely got a lot more out of my
research than that conversation gave me
but
um
it's also helped me sort of reconcile
with the fact that you know
this is actually you know in a lot of
ways it's a gift the way that a bipolar
mind works you know
um
we i think we have the ability to tap
into emotions immediately that and and
and the range is you know it's like
having a 2000 key keyboard and i can i
can hit both the highest and the lowest
al almost without um a delay you know
between and most people can't swing that
but i think being able to feel those
things
gives us uh an advantage in
understanding people and but the highs
and lows are too much you need help but
that's dangerous right if we stay
interesting and if we occupy one space
for too long especially high energy
space is too long that can be very
dangerous you know there's also you know
the danger of like reckless behavior
which is something it's you know i look
back in my life in the past and we start
to go like oh it actually makes a lot of
sense right the things that i've been
dealing with in the seasons of that and
you know it's like okay
and then having a language having a way
to uh to to to talk about that
makes it so much easier to confront it
and you know you don't feel like a freak
or like you're a psycho you know like
you just
it's it's something that we can name and
and there are you know we don't
understand everything about it but we
can understand how to
best
uh craft uh
rituals and routines that help us avoid
some of the more dangerous aspects of
that um kind of uh brain chemistry right
you know and so um you know like my wife
and i she's been amazing i mean she
we talk about this kind of stuff we talk
about suicide we talk about
bipolar mania talk about hype you know
we
we deal with these things
and she talks about it like it's like
i'm going to get butter from the store
really just so such an open forum for it
all i'm like yeah i feel like i [ __ ]
i just want to go in a machine gun
everybody you know she's like okay let's
talk about it you know like that's white
bread i'm going to go get those so you
want sourdough or white bread you know
what it's like you've gone to therapy
before this doctor with bipolar you were
dabbled in it yeah but the kind of
therapy i'd gone to was not for this it
was related it was marriage there was
like marriage counseling right right
right how do we how how you know how do
we who we're married very young um i've
known my wife since high school we
weren't exclusive since then like she
lived a life i lived a life and then we
found each other again it was like where
where was this the whole time right
you're wonderful right um
uh you know
how do we now navigate this world that's
so foreign to what
is
you know i mean the life of a public
figure you know or somebody that's like
working in tv or film is just
it's not something there's no textbook
on how to you know manage that and
there's so many landmines there are so
many landmarks you know um and you
constantly step on them
sometimes you run to them and jump on
them with both feet exactly exactly you
know so um you know learning how to
navigate that together you know um
and for her to learn how to deal with
that you know
realizing that both people out there can
say heinous terrible things to her and
she's done nothing to deserve that you
know like like suddenly she's this
uh piece of conversation for you know
fodder and um
and also that there are people out there
that don't care that um she's married
don't care she's a she's not part of the
equation you know like
um you know uh
it's you know it's just she has to let
go of a lot you know a lot of fear a lot
of anxiety a lot of questions was she
kind of freaked out when you first told
her i have bipolar
oh i think it was like of course oh well
that makes sense yeah oh okay yeah it's
kind of like you're manic and then
you're really yeah would you always can
you tell like that's what you that's
what you'd be you'd be the really
manicure really depressed
you know for her yes but i hadn't really
experienced the depression it was more
a retreat from all of life which has
just always been my ammo like and i it's
not me it's not because i don't like
people i just
live in my head and that's where i
recover and that's a you know that's
something like the textbooks we'll talk
about like there are people especially
like high creatives or highly sensitive
individuals a lot of them
rejuvenate regenerate alone and that's
just always been my thing and so that's
sort of what it looked like you know the
depression was new and it was savage
when it struck it struck someone so just
hit you out of the blue and what what is
an overall feeling do you feel like
you're just
you just want to sleep you're just tired
oh tired
all the negative thoughts um not
understanding how to get motivated i
mean somebody who's worked out forever
and you know my livelihood and i just
didn't have the energy to do it the
energy or wherewithal like i literally
was saying to myself how does anybody
even get up to go to the gym like i i'd
never want to work out again like there
was no motivation to do anything
anything i could not get my feet on the
floor in the morning
when i did i didn't care and you know
and there's also this cynicism to life
you know like why are we even [ __ ]
here you know like
look at how
how much pain is in the world look at
how violent we are to each other
you know everybody is out for blood you
know and everybody's out for themselves
you know it's tough thing to reconcile
and so at the end of the day
learning finding
routines and rituals you know even even
something as simple as like making tea
at night you know it's like something so
kind of uh serene and meditative that it
helps pull my brain out of this like
feisty place that it lives right 24 7.
and you're doing medication you are on
education yeah and that really has
changed your life
sure and you know um i don't know that
i'm on it until i stop taking it and
then my wife goes
are you on your medical don't you talk
to me about medication i don't need i
don't need medication she's like you're
off you're right because i keep thinking
i tell myself like i had to you know go
six months without missing any and i'm
like i'm fine i don't need to do this
the rest of my life i don't need to do
this i'm fine i'm totally fine yeah and
then uh and then the wheels start coming
off and you're like i just can't like
everybody's so
loud everybody's so loud so once you
start you got on this medication once
you started going to this therapy once
you had the realization that hey my
brain chemistry is different than
everybody else's it's just and it just
takes a different kind of effort to all
of a sudden you have the the the thought
the wherewithal to uh i i want to go
work out again i had the desire the
motivation all these things came back
yeah i had to force myself to work out
it was uh i hired a trainer which i've
never done you know i never needed to i
you know i mean i think about it now and
i'm like i can't believe that's where i
was you know
um i'm one of the first businesses i
ever invested in was a fitness franchise
that i ran like i i'm the guy that runs
that stuff i don't need a trainer right
and i had to hire somebody because i was
like this is the only way i'm going to
get in the gym and and uh and i told him
about where i was and he uh his name is
justin fallah he was incredible very
patient with me and
um and helped coax me out of that you
know um so uh i needed to i did what i
threw whatever i could at life to help
me sort of pull through um
but you know faith is a big part of it
for me you know i'm uh you know some
people i i think you know i almost envy
people who
feel like they can they're fine going
through life without any thought of
what's beyond you know right um
i
if that works for you then great i have
to have faith in something
i'm deeply conflicted if not because
otherwise like i don't understand what
what the point of this i mean there's no
there's no way to reconcile the pain in
the world without an ultimate sense of
like hope and justice happening you know
for myself and others i mean there's so
many reasons why you know but it also
makes sense to me it just makes sense
and it makes me want to be a better
person but
i dove into
i dove into that life and uh
started reading everything i could
studying theology trying to understand
like is there a deeper meaning and
purpose here and how does that have a
real impact on my life and for me it's
about
other centeredness you know which is not
something i'd ever
thought of before you know i got so
ambitious still so ambitious
um still such a product of my
industrial era style education that's
like you go be a good worker and that's
what you're contributing to society a
good thing and
um
to turn around and say like actually um
rejecting a lot of those ideas and not
making the material accumulation that we
strive for the most important thing in
our lives and finding ways to think
about other people and give back to that
is actually a more fulfilling and
purposeful and eternal kind of way of
thinking that maybe i'll do that and so
um you know altruism
part of it yeah so there was a
simplification in life like so yeah i
got rid of a house sold all my fancy
cars you know that i was accumulating
and loved and um and it was less about
that and more about like how can i find
a way to get involved in community
involved in other people's lives in a
meaningful way impact the world through
like effective charities or you know
like just how can that changed you oh
yeah
i mean is that not something is that not
something you can do forever and not i
mean you scientifically the
scientifically
scientific studies have proven that that
kind of altruism actually has a true
meaningful impact on our state of
well-being that there is nobody who can
give of themselves purely and not feel
better because of it how is that not
something that can eternally rejuvenate
us like forever and ever like people
talk about like oh i wouldn't want to go
to heaven because i would just get bored
or would it be so boring
i was like no that idea of heaven is a
is a world where everybody's giving of
themselves and that cycle of of of love
is not
it's it's something that continues to
fill us up as we give it away it's this
almost
kind of yes it's this beautiful cycle
that uh never ends you know and that
feels good and you can start that now
and that's what the whole message is all
about i think you know and um and you
weren't doing a lot of that beforehand
giving back or going to hospital i used
to call my agents and be like you
understand who what is this audition for
i'm building an empire here you know i'd
say words like empire like oh so ashamed
now but i would have those like thoughts
at the
delusions of grandeur and all that [ __ ]
totally that's part of bipolar right it
is yeah it is but you know um
you know i mean when you're having the
delusion of grandeur it doesn't feel
like one it feels very possible and very
real and when you accomplish most of
those
then people start to question like well
maybe is it is it you know is it a
delusion
could he actually pull that off like
well he's doing it here maybe he could
you know
inside you is brought to you by magic
spoon
guys it's the new year magic spoon
i love this this company i love this
product
uh magic spoon is perfect for meeting
your goals whether it's eating healthier
or saving more time in your morning
routine
you know as a kid i've talked about this
but you'd love to eat the sugary cereals
i just i could name them all right now
and i didn't realize how bad they were
for me but you know how bad they are the
older you get
they're worse and worse for you your
body you can't function on crap
and so magic spoon has made some
healthy
delicious options
and that's
magic spoon that's what they do magic
spoon has it all zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving only 140
calories a serving it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
build your own box available flavors to
build your very own custom bundle or
cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon cookies and cream and maple
waffle
my mouse watering as i speak
really delicious and uh you know like
i've said before if you're trying to cut
down on carbs trying to cut down these
things but you still want something
delicious my friends have asked me
they've called me is this magic spoon
any good i'm like taste it surprisingly
good you you and i tasted it we had a
tasting experience a while back it's
really good it really is good yeah i
love it um and i'd like some more free
stuff by the way magic spoon it's easy
guys go to magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and start your new year off right and be
sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this podcast inside of you is brought to
you by wondery how do we make the most
of our time here on earth how do we
bring meaning to our life's work and
what is the best emoji to use when
texting these are the important
questions asked on the weekly interview
podcast life is short with justin long i
love justin he's pretty awesome just in
chats with celebrities actors musicians
artists and more about how they get the
most out of life recent guests include
comedian rob riggle and singer amy mann
he digs deep and each episode goes
beyond what you'd expect to hear on an
interview show
and in an all new episode justin talks
with actor billy zane about his long and
storied hollywood career which started
with a small role in back to the future
justin's candid interview style pulls
out some unexpected stories from billy
from his time on set in the new comedy
series magruber to his villainous role
in the international blockbuster titanic
which he admits he secretly played like
a comedy and of course you'll find out
billy zane's favorite emoji too i've had
justin on the podcast um and he's just a
lovely person to be around he's got
great stories a lot of inside
um
and i would recommend listening to him
listen to life is short with justin long
on apple podcasts amazon music or you
can listen ad free by joining wondering
plus in the wondery app
that's pretty incredible it's incredible
that
you were able to overcome this
because you hit rock bottom as rock
bottom as someone can hit and you pulled
you literally
pulled yourself out of it well i would
say
am overcoming this i mean it's sort of
like like yeah yeah hey style right like
i don't think i don't think i'm ever
through it you know and honestly like if
there's anything that still tortures me
the past tortures me not being able to
modify it at all um but the other thing
would be um
reconciling the fact that like there's a
possibly a lot of a lot of years left to
continue on a path that is you know
that is fulfilling you know and like it
seems daunting at times you know it
seems daunting to think like oh i
haven't overcome that that's still very
much a possibility or a part of me i
have to continue to overcome it day by
day you know um
taking those steps
you know there's thousands of them left
in front of me you know possibly you
know it's uh that sometimes is
overwhelming you know well what's over
overwhelming as well what could be
daunting is taking on a role like jack
reacher i mean to get back into that a
little bit i mean that's that's a big
you know that's tom cruise big time
movie blockbuster and then they're doing
a series how many auditions did you go
on how many times did you meet with
these producers for this role
yeah you know there's always going to be
a chip on my shoulder for this because
uh you know i'm also i'm just always
going to feel like i have something to
prove no matter how many times you know
i just went to dinner with a lot of
people involved with the show and they
were like thanking me because it shows
you know it's not out
yet i mean i don't know when this will
air but you know when we're talking
about this right now it's not out yet
but does it come out on amazon february
4th so um so
it's being seen by some people media you
know industry insiders test audience and
it's like everybody loves it you know
people that have read the books people
that haven't everybody's enjoying it so
i thank you for all your hard work and
what you've done and if it if you if you
didn't work as reacher this whole thing
wouldn't work but it work
and i you know and i think back to my my
time during the process they passed on
me the first time
and they passed on everybody their first
time you know but um
you know i've put i put a tape together
you know i was approached about this as
was probably 2 000 other guys and um
and i you know i put a tape together but
this the sides that they gave us were
probably not the most conducive to an
audition because it was all about
capturing that stoic you know reach or
said nothing is something sort of
famously involved in every book reacher
said nothing and the sides were
basically reacher said nothing so
there's like an interrogation where he's
just sitting there the whole time and i
was like i don't know how to play this
but in my mind i was like i have to you
know it's got to have some energy and so
i was channeling you know the guy from
water world who's like give me the paper
give me the paper give it a go give it a
paper he's trying to trade the paper for
the girls give me the paper give me the
paper
kevin costner's like all right don't put
the knife down
i was like trying to channel that guy
they give me the paper give me the paper
guy
in my mind i'm like listening you know
imagining this guy trying to just
generate some inner something or yeah
and uh and they hated it they hated it
so they just said okay no pass no i went
to pretty you know the tape went to
produce i got a call that you know they
you know it was
it was interesting they sent it to
producers and then it just never went
further and like months go by and like
you know i've been doing this a long
time you hold very loosely to this stuff
like oh love the idea of that that'd be
cool and then nothing happens you're
like okay that wasn't me that was meant
for somebody else and it was sort of
that it was just like all right i guess
meant for somebody else
and then like i don't know
four or five months after that
i get a call that like they're thinking
about
redo it you know sort of coming circling
back
um
new casting director and whole new sides
their re kind of re-imagining this
process and so they were like i was like
oh i'll get a second chance and so mindy
marin who who casts uh who casts the
show she's a phenomenal casting director
she had gone back to look at the tapes
after they reimagined how to approach
finding this guy and looked at the tapes
that have gone to producers so like
thank god they sent it to producers that
time because i never would have been
seen again um and uh
she saw you saw something she saw
something in it i think with
some adjustment you know i think with
some adjustment we could you know get
this to work
but i when i saw the new size i was like
oh this i can do
you know um and so yeah it was probably
seven or eight other auditions seven or
eight other auditions there are so many
cooks in the kitchen in a in a good way
like not in i mean there are so many
people who have a vested interest in
delivering something
that works to the fans as they should
you know it's a lot of people taking
this very seriously and want to make
sure that they get it right and
you know some
i
i only owe
mr cruz a debt of gratitude for the
visibility that he's brought to this
role but there are people who comment on
the fact that he's not exactly the size
that reaches should be and that's a
large character in this
it's its own kind of character in this
um
guy than cruz
and that's true that's true but um you
know and you know it's suffices to say
that he he also still carried those
franchises into the hundreds of millions
of dollars without that so that's a
testament to him and his his talent and
craft right he's incredible um um but
you know a lot of fans um weren't happy
and um and so
you know there's obviously probably a
level of anxiety from the executives
going like we don't want to mess this up
again and so there's a lot of that
energy
uh coming coming at these these
auditions you know um sort of a little
bit of trepidation
and uh
it you know it it it kept going but it
was like well now we want you to
read for you know the amazon exactly
this guy dance exactly this exact that
exactly
where are you going
along the way no not at all it was like
okay as long as this is happening as
long as this conversation is happening
like then this is still good you know
and it's just another opportunity for me
to win somebody over this is the job you
know how it is like i think as soon as
you get cynical i was there was a point
in my life where i was like very soon i
came off a comedy and uh i felt like
i mean infant you know they should be
throwing roles at me like look what i
just did on the show that nobody saw
delusions of grandeur delusions of
grandeur and i was like frustrated that
like you know there weren't just like 50
film offer you know
it was and you know i got very bitter
for a little bit until i had this
um
this uh
perspective shift you know um through
the loss of a roll but uh
um you know so it just i was up for it i
was up for it as long as it was working
and it was you know but it was it took a
lot of
educating um
amazon on who i you know
who i am and
and then there was also a lot of
questions about hype because this is
during the pandemic so we can't do this
stuff in person and in fact they flew me
out once to to test in person and uh
and and i get to the hotel in la and
they're like
they're gonna have to take a blood
sample this is like before
you know the swabs that we have now and
they're like they're gonna take blood
sample and i was like blood sample
i'm like this is serious like this is
what's kind of like this world are we
really gotta bleed for your craft these
days
yeah i guess that's the world that was
fine with it i was like all right that's
fine
they're like all right they're talking
to lawyers about it seeing you know how
that whole thing works and i guess
eventually they got cold feet about
taking blood to to secure a test
audition um and so i went back and we
did it over zoom
but uh
you know i wasn't seeing these people in
person and that's a big part of this you
know knowing you can feel somebody's
energy and their presence and see their
size and so so they
they actually had me measure myself
on tape you know like head to toe and i
couldn't you know i couldn't do it so i
had my kids on a step stool and they're
up there like measuring
like strip down your shorts and bare
feet show us exactly where that tape is
we want to see how big you saw you
without a shirt on and all that oh yeah
yeah yeah um uh you know so there was
just it was a lot of that it was a big
process of like you were in really good
shape at this time
well i was uh
yeah i was
i walk around it like you know if i'm
not working out i run a lot and i walk
around like 205 which is like still big
for a lot of people right um
and uh 205 i think if i thought you'd be
bigger than that well i am now oh you
are yeah i'm 235. oh okay yeah i was
like jesus christ yeah that's like 185
i'm like
yeah yeah i put i put on i put out about
30 pounds for this you know um but uh
yeah i wasn't at the time you know i
wasn't that big of that but you know i
still
i'm just a large guy you know a guy it's
a large man it was just
um anyway but it just uh it it was a
process and um and uh they were
convinced that um
you know i was i guess i was the right
guy so there was a lot of there was a
lot of apprehension when the the
executive's producers started showing up
in prep when i was actually there
because i was like now they're going to
see me in person for the first time i
hope i'm big enough
and you were and i think thank god yeah
well didn't get fired here's a serious
question yeah how honestly
how demanding
was the shoot that's a good question i
mean you filmed this entire 10 episode
series
you did 10 episodes for this amazon
series jack reacher which comes out
february 4th
the demand on your body and your mind i
mean you just talked about in your
mid-30s overcoming
you know deep depression and figuring
out you have bipolar getting on meds
getting healthier finding purpose you
book this part i guess it's the right
time because you're now on the up
what are you going through
that's a good question um
i think i think uh you know and also for
anybody watching who maybe is struggling
with a lot of that stuff bringing all
that stuff to the light can only help
you know i feel like we live in a world
where it's you know i'm trying to
destigmatize normalize these
conversations so we could just
let's just get it let's talk about it
you know that's about it
this is only it can only help to talk
about it but you know i had an assistant
on the show and she's well aware of all
of that you know and so it was like help
me
pay attention to you because it's hard
for me to see
those changes you know um you know am i
am i do how am i doing mentally you know
like and and you know and she's like if
uh if you need to slow down like let's
just slow down at any time of course i
never said i needed to but
um but you should have
but you can't you know i mean you know
there's like you know yeah
so
the toughest thing i don't ever want to
complain
about i have nothing to complain about i
live a privilege a privileged life and
uh i've i've always
i'm living the dream that i i've worked
for you know i mean it's a dream come
true you know what i do for a living i
enjoy um it challenges me it keeps me
holds my interest nothing else can you
know i'm just i get bored easily i love
what i do i don't want to complain but
it was the most challenging shoot i've
ever had to endure and it just about
killed me
really
yes and i do i mean that i mean that i'm
gonna you'll you're gonna get some info
that no no other i've given any other
media or whatever but i'll just get into
it with you because i
i really care i've watched your show for
a long time i care about what you do
here thank you um so
i think it's also important for people
to know this stuff that i now know
while i'm going through the show
they asked me
right out of the gate before we start
shooting this so um are you okay
shooting seven days a week
like
seven days a week
like how's it enough is that even
legal where's my union
that's exactly what it's like yeah guys
is that allowed like and they're like
yeah you know we'll figure it out but we
need to we need to shoot that fact and i
was like why the show's never been on
it's not like we're trying to hit an air
date it's never been on we finished when
we finished you know they're like no
we've been given a date where the the
money shuts off if we're not done by
then it's july 31st that only gives us
this amount of time it wasn't enough
time to shoot the show and so they're
like that's the way we can fix it is
just shoot round the clock and i'm like
when am i going to sleep when am i going
to eat when am i going to study when am
i going to rehearse the fights like what
all that all those questions are like
we'll just have to figure it out the
lead and they go okay so i was like no
i'm not i mean just you know just for
practical reasons i think seven is a
foolish number like working seven it's
an impossibility
for a lead actor it is
people have no idea people have no
possibility i have no idea
um
and uh and i was like i you know but i
also like i don't really think i should
be working on sundays you know for for a
lot of reasons let's just say no again i
just say no and they're like all right
well there's a couple we'll have to have
you and i was like i don't know man and
like split but it'll be six days a week
then and i was like all right
like six days is a lie that's still a
lot you know but i was like all right my
last contract i was lucky enough to go
weekends off no six days every other
friday off oh and it was a comedy and it
was like oh yeah it was just a dream
yeah it was a dream but like i couldn't
imagine working every day as the lead
actor i just like fall apart i'm too old
yeah and i felt that yeah i felt that
and uh and so i was like all right you
know i'm a team player i guess if that's
what we got to do that's what we got to
do i don't understand it but okay
and they were like you know the way that
they solve that problem because the
crews can't work six days a week they
can't do that so they get their five
days or so what we ended up doing was
they were shooting something basically
seven days a week and uh i was on six of
those days but i was i was swinging both
crews so i would i would even leave the
first
crew on like a tuesday when i'm like
normally oh my one scene for the day is
not actually only have one scene today
holy cow
and they're like actually we we packed
in the second you're actually gonna go
shoot some stuff with the second crew
today so it was like never ending and
and if there was a day that was that was
naturally like one or two scenes that
was that was pat it was filled there was
no time i was doing stunt fight training
in parking lots of sets that we were
working in like between takes like okay
get back out to the thing we gotta learn
the you know the stairwell fight or
whatever i'm like all right and i come
back into the scene i'm sweating the
makeup artist like what are you doing
why are you sweaty i just oh we gotta
we've gotta blow dry his hair you know
we were shooting here and like you don't
look anything like you did on the other
side i'm like i'm sorry i was fist
fighting the parking lot it was nuts man
i was like there was not talk about like
finding a place to calm that brain wave
down it was not when did you hit a wall
um it was when my you know i started
getting injured i started getting
injured and i started
i started to vocalize about halfway
through
i think this is too much like even for
me who i can push myself through like i
only need like two more months of this
but i
i'm falling apart like i can't do it i'm
sleeping three hours a night even on
nights when i could get six or seven
hours of sleep i would wake up at three
hours it was like my body was whacked
i was we were shooting night shoots
cause i was six days usually your night
shoots are friday night
and then you get home at like six in the
morning on saturday and you have
saturday night to sleep and then sunday
night into like a five a.m call on
monday
you start back on days on monday we were
shooting six days though so my so i
would actually go home at like six or
seven in the morning on sunday morning
and then i'm back into my 5 a.m on
monday that doesn't work like when did
no i was i was i was out of my mind
and so so i started getting injured and
you know we bring these doctors in
and i'm like just get me through the
shoot whatever it takes and so they gave
me these super powerful nsaids that are
ibuprofen on steroids you know right not
opiates or painkillers or anything this
is like you know i'm thinking
this is great this takes and i'm like i
can't lift my arm and i'm like major
issues with my shoulder i tore in
oblique
i was like i was working hard
there was a scene
there was a scene where um
i i can see this in the show i'm gonna
i'll tell you i'll tell you this now i
guess i'll ruin it for you but there's
there's a scene where um i'm in a prison
and i have to eat a sandwich
and i could i was having trouble
breathing like i couldn't get enough
oxygen and i know i i know what it is
now and i there's a medical diagnosis
now that i'm getting fixed but
i could i was suffocating just living
right and so then i do the fights and i
was like
dying you know so i'm going i'm eating a
sandwich like how easy is that and i was
i felt like i was gonna pass out i could
not breathe and i couldn't and the food
was in the way so i was like and so you
can see if you watch the scene closely
i'm trying to deliver my lines and
breathe at the same time and it sounds
like i'm i just ran a marathon like i'm
500 pounds i'm like
i'm dying dying
all those n says that they were giving
me
killed testosterone i had no
testosterone in my body i got a blood
panel later after i got back i had
surgery on my shoulder to fix whatever
was going on there because it was broken
from from that shoot and
the reason everything was tearing was
because there's no oxygen getting to my
muscles because there was no hemoglobin
testosterone helps form hemoglobin in
the body hemoglobin is what brings
oxygen to your cells i literally was
suffocating to death because of all the
powerful
pain meds that were helping me get
through those fights i thought i was
helping myself push through and do it i
was doing a lot of damage no sleep
um all the physicality no rest and then
all those pain medications lowering my
testosterone to nothing
i couldn't i was dying i was dying you
can hear it in some of the scenes it's
crazy crazy and uh people don't know the
kind of drain that you know that kind of
what you put your body through to
survive that kind of stuff but this was
intense um so what you're saying is
if this is a huge hit which i hope it
will be
then there'll be some adjustments for
the next scene that was already agreed
upon yeah well there you go yeah
i i told him i was like guys i can now i
can't do this again and like if you
think we're gonna do this for
seven eight ten years however many books
we wanna do which i wanna do them all
this is unsustainable you know they're
like we agree it was just this arbitrary
date one time now that we know what it
takes to get this done we'll never do
this to you again if you finish the
season the way that you have we promised
never to do it again and i was like deal
um
and did you think that you weren't going
to be able to make it through
yeah there was i had questions there
were times you know and then i had
people going like just two weeks left
you've got this you've got this but
you're like on you're like oh my god did
you have any anxiety as well
from being so fatigued or being it was
more of frustration like i was just mad
i was like mad i'm not mad at anybody i
just like i had such a low few i had no
fuse which is like i had no fuel can you
fault me i don't know i had no i wasn't
sleeping i i wasn't oh so you were angry
oh yeah i was like like like people
would come over like we need to switch
your boots out i'm like [ __ ] damn it
i had no i couldn't tolerate humans or
sound or
anything and i'd get myself
you know i would study i didn't have
time to study because i didn't you know
i'd shoot all day it's like major huge
so you just had to learn the scenes on
the fly so i set up a system on my
computer where i had headphones on set
in a little office that they would bring
around for me and between takes i'd
learn
next episodes side you know scenes you
know and so i'd be doing i'd go do like
a five-page monologue and then in the
off you know in between takes i'm
learning like a five-page monologue for
the next episode so it was like this
never-ending you had big monologues oh
dude for reacher said nothing this guy
talks a lot
for a guy that has nothing to say i was
like guys can we just have a narrator
can we have me narrate like uh like you
know
dexter or something like can i just say
like no we need you but now you know
this people listening to this are
thinking man this must be an intense
[ __ ] action-packed series yeah but
then you but i watch it i'm like i don't
see any of the you know the feeling that
i had in my body like that's cause
you're rehearsing constantly you're
fighting choreography right he seems
laid laid-back and cool as a cucumber on
screen so i'm like i don't know hey it
worked maybe i'm just a baby i don't
know
uh
but uh but i but you know this is worth
talking about the nsaids ibuprofen and
that kind of thing now i understand
having gotten a blood panel done and
realizing
it was all about low testosterone caused
by the nsaids
uh
you know maybe there's a sort of an
extreme fatigue attached to that because
of the nature of our work but
uh
ibuprofen nsaids
destroy your testosterone and if men are
out there feeling tired or fatigued or
wondering why you know it's a mood
stabilizer feeling like you have a short
fuse you don't really you know you can't
get motivated to go to the gym it might
be
that you
you know like me take ibuprofen every
day because you've got back pain or neck
pain or whatever and you don't have any
testosterone and maybe you need to get
on testosterone therapy which is super
easy to do yeah and
you know do the patch or the shot or
whatever you know and uh
and sit you know since uh you know so i
started taking testosterone to get my
numbers back up and uh night and day i
feel like oh god like this is how i felt
before the shoot and this is how i
should feel all the time um
i didn't know that i mean did did
anybody ever tell you that ibuprofen
will kill your testosterone no no of
course they didn't tell you that they
just want to siphon your money away
and you know so you take away the pain
for whatever you're feeling at the time
but man like nobody tells you this stuff
jesus you know
i this has been incredible because you
have just opened up so much that i i
love when guests we had a guest last
week that just opened up and at the end
i'm like [ __ ] that's
it's so refreshing
and so nice to see someone in the
business who's doing really well talk
about how hard
what they've been through right and how
to overcome it and
just really but breaking it down
not just
you know
because
usually people look at us and they're
like oh actors come on you guys get
spoon fed in this but to hear your story
and hear all these things that you went
through and you're a human being
and to not realize to your 36 that you
had bipolar is just
that's tough yep that's some tough times
that you've had to overcome and this has
only been a couple years you've gone
through all this right the role of a
lifetime
that the the chance of a lifetime to
kind of rebound and and you know
save yourself right it's just it's just
extraordinary um this is called
uh [ __ ] talking with alan richton um
these are my patrons these are lovable
patrons who they give back to the
podcast they
i couldn't do it without them
uh they're amazing people and they have
some questions so kind of rapid fire
michelle kay
yay
love allen
how does he manage to keep such a
positive mindset in such a unpredictable
industry what's the secret formula well
we've talked about that yeah but what
would you say
in a nutshell if you had to say in one
sentence
what would that be i think it's about
identity
so my identity is no longer in my career
my work my identity is something that's
uh far more palatable like like i said
uh serving others like how can i even
you know just for people i pass in the
gas station you know like
can i open the door for them would that
make their day better can i you know are
they having a hard time how can i
approach the world and seize every
opportunity to make somebody's life
better that is where i want my identity
to be to be found and uh and in serving
others you know and
you know if i lose a role or i don't get
an you know an audition doesn't go my
way or i don't whatever that doesn't
matter i've got my identities rooted in
something else
that is beautiful leanne if you could
only put one thing on your bucket list
what would it be
uh i mean i've done a lot i've lived a
crazy life um but i think now for my
bucket list is uh is all about travel
with my kids i my entire
goal for my kids is to open their worlds
up as big as possible um
and they started you know we've so we
talk about travel and we talk about
exploring the world and having
adventures and um
they uh they started they said uh how to
they said out of nowhere they said um
i want to give up my birthday next year
and travel instead and i was like what
what a mature
wonderful thing to hear out of your
young you know wow nine-year-old you
know seven-year-old um
and they're all like yeah i'm like where
do you want to go like i want to go to
australia why do you want to go there
because they have like the bearded
dragons and i want to go see this and
like this is that's wonderful you love
this yes that's what i live for now you
know so so my bucket list is all about
my kids um my kid's bucket list
david h did you meet tom cruise before
taking over his role in reacher
um no we've never we've been you know
we've
he was we've never met i'll just say
that
all right yeah i met him before a couple
times he's
incredibly nice right right incredibly
right like hey i go hey good to see you
guys we met we met hold on we met at
mike binder's house and i'm like oh my
god why would you remember me oh and you
had yeah i was i was i was hoping you'd
say like we met at uh
the paramount party and you've never had
no and he remembered me from meeting me
in another party incredible dave p what
was it like to have the
bms boys back together at mountaineer
con blue mountain state boys uh yeah
blue mountain state will always uh
take up an um memorable part of my
uh mind but i love those guys you know
we uh it was you know fun
college football comedy and um and the
chemistry that we had on that show will
never be replicated on any other show i
just know what we had was special um so
anytime we get to hang together it's fun
danny yay when did allen realize he had
a flare for comedic roles he's got great
delivery oh thanks oh guys well
yeah yeah tell my wife that she was like
how many eye rolls i get at home from my
one-liners you know what i need to let
you answer that one yeah you don't even
need to [ __ ] answer that
you probably realized that as a young
kid
no man i didn't you know i was an idiot
and people hated me when i was young i
why was ace ventura
like six halloweens in a row at school
you know i'd go to school i just was
enamored with jim carrey i was enamored
his physicality and how funny he was
and uh nobody else thought it was funny
and so i'd like walk up to kids at lunch
and like tur like talk out of my ass in
front of their plate of like cheerios or
whatever excuse me may i ask you a
question you know and they're like get
the [ __ ] out of here richton
they hated me i was so annoying i love
that so i didn't i didn't know that it
had some you know it's a redeeming
qualities sebastian k how pissed were
you and justin hartley played aquaman in
the spin-off and you didn't
because you were aquaman on [ __ ]
smallville with me yeah that's right no
i wasn't mad at all why would i be mad
well because you know like why didn't
they consider you well they did but they
uh
people don't know you know what i went
through with that but
you know i didn't i hadn't done anything
at the time i didn't i hadn't said
marvel was your first is it my first gig
first gig like you seeing you on a set
you know making jokes and whatever i was
like god he's so relaxed you know like
you're the first thing i ever saw yeah
like you're my mom basically i'm like a
little dinosaur coming out of the shell
let's see you first son yeah
yeah because it was your first role it
was my first thing first speaking role i
was so overwhelmed i was like how many
people are so many people on this set
i never knew that was your first role i
never knew until i read about it but i
remember on set i was like he's just
great he's doing a great job
i've always been good at faking it you
know you were faking it oh wow yeah i
didn't know what i was doing and so the
you know the i i was told that the
episode that i i was on season five the
first one that i came on it was a
well-oiled machine at that point
it was uh
it was like a ratings record that
episode you know which was like
astounding having been on for that like
it did really well apparently so they
wanted to green light a spin-off and
they were like congratulations and i was
getting calls from people the studio
like i'm the guy who's just here to make
sure you keep your head on the ground so
you call me day or night if you're in
trouble i'm like you know i was like
what is this
oh yeah these people were like prepping
me for like the biggest show on tv i'm
like okay and we start working on a deal
and at the time upn and warner brothers
had merged to create the cw and the
president of the upn had taken over and
he's looking at this roster of shows
uh the slate and going uh who the hell
is that guy
which is the same thing i would do i
mean i was sitting there going like i
can't believe it was this easy i've been
here three weeks i got my own show
oh my gosh so they just he just axed it
next to it and he goes
he can't be he can't have his own show
and so they called me and they're like
we're trying to fight him on it because
we looked for so long and we love you
but he doesn't want you to do this we
have to go back and find people but
maybe we won't find anybody and they did
they didn't they went back and they
didn't find anybody and so they came
back again and they're like so he said
fine he'll give it a shot you know we'll
do the pilot together and i was like
great okay great i can get my own show
you know i'm sitting cool
but you know but again like like with
reacher there's this asterisk by for me
where i'm like i guess i'm not really
wanted but maybe i'll run with it as you
know
so it's like it had been taken from me
and then like a week later they were
like actually
justin hartley just came off passions
and uh he's available and we're gonna go
with justin hartley and i was like i
don't know who that is but great you
know good for you and uh and i
i learned the best lesson i could
early on to hold loosely to this stuff
because nothing is guaranteed and
nothing's owed to me and if i hadn't
learned that lesson early i would have
been an entitled [ __ ] um i probably
still am but uh much greater degrees
um you know so uh it taught me to hold
you know told real loosely to this stuff
and i think that's a great lesson to
have right out of the gate so i'm
grateful that i didn't get in and i also
you know if i would have gotten that
show i never would have learned
really learned the craft or studied
myself
i would have just floated on whatever
shows that gate you know that would have
had some ancillary you're gonna get this
movie because you were on that show
and um
i've had a very different experience
where i've had to like
really
uh you know f find my voice you know and
speaking of voice lastly i'll let you go
after this
i had no idea you were a singer you were
like you were like 87th on american idol
you you did a strip tease in front of
what's her name paula paula abdul
uh i didn't know you you went to school
for singing like you're a trained singer
yeah it was i was a music theater major
until i quit school because i was like
why would i what i mean what degree
would i use like walk into the broadway
audition and go like here's my degree
from
do you still want to like sing do you
want to have your own album do you want
to ever do no not my own album no no um
but uh i do love writing i sometimes
i'll write for people but um but i my
goal is to marry you know uh like la la
land i think is one of my favorite
movies of all time good movie to that
you know the way that they so
effectively married
music and theater and film is my goal
yes
my secret passion is yes i gotta find
the newsies was my favorite movie
growing up as a kid every year
we we would get if we got straight a's
the network video
would allow you a free rental and so i
was always like a very studious little
academic i want straight a's just so i
can go rent the newsies
and every time i walk in the newsies is
over there it was never checked out you
know
it's over there
i walk into my report card i walk out
with it i watched it a million times on
vhs when i was growing up because i just
i thought it was just the coolest you
know what do you sing in the shower
what's the one song you sing
oh i don't know the newsies santa fe
are you there do you swear you won't
forget me
see look at that just hit something just
like that what about any 80s classics i
don't know 80s classics duran duran yeah
how about a duran duran song i don't
know any of those i was into uh
i was in an instinct yeah i was a 90s
what do you what do you sing from nsync
oh what's that song that they had that
like justin
uh uh
oh yeah yeah uh
god must just spend
a little more time
on you
on you on you are you you
remember that one yes yeah that one i
used amazing i'd like sarah knight like
every sixth grade girl i was interested
i just be like on my knees i started
saying oh you
your wife love when you sing to her
i don't see i don't sing to my wife you
don't see your wife why would i sing to
my wife oh this is kind of cute
i already bagged that one i don't have
to get on my knees and get sick
dude this has been this has been a real
treat i can't express to you how much i
enjoyed this i didn't i didn't know how
much i enjoy i know i like you i know
you're a good guy
but i
you just opened the hell up and it means
a lot to me it means a lot to the people
listening on the show i know they're
gonna they're gonna just grave about you
because you were open up so i appreciate
and i appreciate and look i wish you the
best of luck with drac reacher february
4th it takes off you guys you don't want
to miss it there were 12 [ __ ] books
that ryan and i didn't read one
and and uh you were also ryan says you
were hilarious on brooklyn nine-nine one
of the funniest songs yeah yeah yeah
right ryan
yeah it just connected the dots today
but yeah that was
this is so good because yeah there's
these two characters hitchcock and
scully they're these two schlubs
who just sort of mainline meatball subs
at the precinct and they take naps and
uh but then
like season six they decided to like
just open with this cold open of these
two hot young cops doing like an 80s
cocaine bust and you were scully
and it was just so gratifying like at
the end of it to go like
like you've like revealed that you were
hitchcock and scully but then um but
then the other downfall at the end is
they do a drug bust at a chicken uh
restaurant and they just tried to
discover chicken wings for the first
time and then like that's when it just
stops it was just so funny like it was
just like having to watch the show it
was just such an integral part it's like
it's uh you impressed ryan it's that's
not easy for sure my favorite cold open
of the entire show the 99 fans are a
sophisticated bunch that's saying thank
you very much it was so great it was
worth such a payoff so good this has
been a real treat thanks man thanks for
having me thanks for doing this and uh
thanks for allowing us to come open up
and hopefully connect uh connect a
little bit more you know thanks for
having me
when he talked about like almost ending
his own life i think about that weekly
isn't that something you know how
impactful that could be that he was so
forthcoming well yeah i mean he comes in
here with his
muscles in his face beautiful beautiful
guy talented guy and then he opened and
then he drops that story on you go holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it really it puts a
lot of things in perspective i was just
going to say that it certainly does you
just kind of go what brings a person to
that dark place and i've been in some
dark places and
you know you just have to realize that
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
and hey if you're feeling those feelings
get some help you can get some help and
uh
therapy call a crisis center like hey if
you're feeling that low man say [ __ ]
you know i have a close friend who
checked himself into uh the psychiatric
word at the hospital he says i'm not
well damn and uh
good for him you know bear with all yeah
yeah we want to you want to live what
the hell if we're only here at one time
it's just like it's going to be hard
it's going to be tough live and to
clarify the light at the end of the
tunnel not like the light of stand alive
not the one you see when you die yes
yes i think they got that
just though for me oh for you for me i
just want to see you yeah okay well that
makes more sense okay i appreciate that
thank you for you know bringing that up
uh thank you again if you like the show
today
follow us on our handles ryan what are
they inside of you pod on twitter inside
of you podcast on instagram and facebook
that is correct and uh we await your
your messages you could write a review
on apple spotify please write a review
on spotify
cumulus has asked me to
mention that a few times and it really
helps the podcast so write a review on
spotify if you're listening right now
we'll take you a minute
and follow us and uh i'd love for you to
join patreon patreon.com inside of you
if you want to give a little more to the
podcast i'll message you right after you
do so or right when i see the message
i'm on cameo uh the inside eu online
store is open we've got great stuff
there i've talked about that um
a really great podcast today i was
really impressed with alan and uh
well that's all i could say i i just was
uh sort of taken aback a few times
by his honesty yeah and uh i thank you
alan for doing that uh we're gonna talk
we're going to give shout outs right now
to the top tier patrons these are people
who give back like i've said a million
times they get back to the podcast in
more ways and you can imagine they keep
the show going
and i love them dearly uh here they are
in fact patrons i hope you saw the video
that i put up on patreon
i put a video up thanking everybody it
was for the 200th episode
congratulations ryan 200 episodes jesus
200 [ __ ] episodes
wow yeah huh 200 huh that's something i
didn't think i'd pass two i almost quit
many times
and here we are you're just kind of like
no one's listening no one gives a [ __ ]
let's just let's just get out of here
and you keep me going here are the top
patrons here we go nancy d leah s sarah
v little lisa yukiko jill e bryan h nico
p robert b jason w christian k amelia o
allison el raj c joshua d cjp jennifer n
stacy l
just like that
uh jen asked jamal f janelle b roger s
kimberly e mike e eldon soprano 99 more
ra mira san diego m chad w liam p janine
r maya p matty s belinda and chris h
dave
h correct spider-man chase sheila g brad
d
ray h tabitha
t
tom and liliana a michelle k talia m
betsy
d chad l rochelle marion
marion
marion name a tv show with marion as the
character happy days no remember happy
days mom totally
med k dan and angel n m angel m rhiannon
c nice corey k super sam coleman g dev
nixon dev nixon yes michelle a jeremy c
cody r gavinator david c john b brandy
uh l d damn yeah
four yavor camille asked the c joey m
willie f christina e adelaide n omar i
lena n
eugene and leah chris p nikki g
who else we got here if you left corey
patricia heather l jake b
is that a jake b
bobbitt ed a at a we
able we said abel right a b e l yeah
abel
joshua b tony g sean r and megan t
without the uh
patrons again i don't know where this
podcast would be so i thank you dearly
and um you know thank god for our
sponsors you know sponsors are here and
hopefully people
react respond you know to a lot of these
uh sponsors that uh you know because
what happens is they
buy a spot for your show
and if they see that people are using
the spot the codes and things then they
stick around and if not they're like see
you
and you can't really control that other
than
trying to sell the product that you
believe in yeah so you spend a lot of
time
saying yes i'll read endorsements for
this because i believe in this company
or i believe you know what i mean it's
it's uh it's not easy it's not easy you
can't expect your listeners to always
not be fast forwarding through [ __ ] and
you hope they don't
so thanks for putting up with me is
there anything else we need to talk
about
200 episodes uh patreon uh you know all
that stuff i think we've got great
guests coming up i really have a lot of
great guests coming up and uh the last
two months of guests have been awesome
you know we had jensen and uh tom
welling and brad brandon routh and uh
angie harmon and chris diamantopoulos
yeah uh you know he was a great guest
and a lot of people don't know him and
he's not on social media and so it's
hard you think who's going to watch this
who's going to listen and i urge you to
listen to the last podcast with
christian metopolis because you're going
to love him his impressions
he does
uncanny uh johnny carson and robin
williams and
three stooges mo and his story about the
three stooges with the fairly brothers
how they paid him nothing to do the lead
role in that movie
so i urge you to listen to some uh
podcasts that you may not be interested
in christian mentopolis but i'm going to
let you know about that thank you for
listening today wherever you are thanks
for spending an hour with us uh really
means a lot to me and uh can't wait to
uh give you some big news that's coming
up
can't really talk about it yet but uh
it's it's really fun and i think uh i
think you're gonna dig it
but until then i am uh michael rosenbaum
from the hollywood hills of california
i'm ryan taylor's from the hollywood
hills of california hey baby teleporter
a little wave to the camera we love you
guys be good to yourselves all right be
good to yourselves i heard a good quote
it's very simple but it was effective
it was
yesterday is history
tomorrow is a mystery today is a gift
and that's why it's called the present
yesterday is history
tomorrow's a mystery
today is a
gift that's why they call it the present
i i like it was that martha stewart no
but i dig it i saw it and it kind of put
a tear in my i'm like you know sometimes
you need to pay attention to the to the
obvious we're here right now
stop worrying about the future stop
worrying about the past we're here we're
in this moment so just remember that i
hope you have a glorious day and come
visit us next week we'll keep the light
on for you i'm allowed to say that yeah
all right great see you guys
[Music]